deux autres professionnels du rire sont
sur les planches pour ce qui constitue
l'événement théâtral de cet automne un
couple assez inattendu muriel robin et
pierre richard pour deux pièces de
feydeau on purge bébé et feu la mère de
madame
thiriez et patrick roy
le calme avant la tempête une tempête de
mots il a la réputation d'être distrait
mais depuis quelques temps pierre
richard serait plutôt un homme pressé
les les costumes
après c'est le texte a pressé les
répétitions après c'est la coiffure
enfin bref c'est vrai que pour l'instant
je peux pas dire que je vais me dit cool
celle à laquelle j'étais habitué avant
paresseuse comme le fleuve aller
montrer plus qu'elles portent pas 28 ans
qui n'avait pas repris le chemin du
terme
de quoi être un peu stressée voir
attention
pressé stressé on stresse et pressé mais
toujours précis j'y vais il m'a giflé
feydeau une mécanique impitoyable un
concerto en double croche avec une
exigence respecter le tempo fédou avant
l'heure c'est pas l'heure après l'heure
c'est plus l'heure
ça c'est faux faux faux être pile dessus
c'est pour ça que c'est si difficile à
jouer ça là y'a pas le temps les plaques
la clac clac
mais pas que là c'est la claque mois
plus parce que justement si c'est si si
c'est trop ça va pas non plus face à
l'heure il faut il faut être à l'heure
mais pile bonjour c'est moi dans deux
jours la première catastrophe
il manque toujours un acteur est celui
qui a le rôle principal dans toutes les
pièces de feydeau le public
elle fait qu'il soit là déjà ça sera
bien et si on les entend rire aussi
simple que ce soir c'est vrai que ça
manque quand on rappelle quelque chose
de drôle est que y'a plus haut peut pas
se dire mais pour qui pourquoi pas tous
à la plus beaucoup de sens donc que vont
nous donner une raison vous nous dire
pourquoi on est là voilà
en attendant que soient vos ce sont eux
qui s'amusent qui s'amusent en apparence
car feydeau c'est avant tout l'exigence
il